this is like a fellas show I like it
well congratulations on the film I was
telling our backstage you have to be
just like freaking out this is a really
great film that y'all are part of you
all did a really really fantastic job if
any of y'all played basketball you want
to tell everybody you're in a basketball
movie so I'm gonna lead with that no
I've never picked up a basketball I'm a
football guy yeah when that audition
comes up you're like yeah I play all the
time like my manager live for me she
told production that I scored 17 points
10 assists 6 rebounds and they thought
it was great until they saw me in person
[Laughter]
I played a basketball on television a
few times I went from playing like the
best basketball player in the country or
high school best basketball playing the
NBA and I got to play Marcus it was the
worst player so what about you will I
grew up playing baseball and then I
slowly like realized that I wasn't that
great at baseball and then I wasn't
gonna do anything with it and kind of
became a feeder band NERD instead and
did like trombone and theater and but I
you know for this movie I worked on my
shot a lot so I hope it I hope it paid
off I know I'm like all those
three-pointers we don't know if it went
in they cut me oh yeah I've been playing
basketball my whole life I've been
playing all sports I was terrible as a
child but and then I like kind of picks
it up a little bit more and I had a
little foundation bringing yeah thanks
to this they are you know they had a
really challenging thing which was the
audition was not just the acting but
they were also also auditioned playing
basketball so the finalists as actors
were all playing massive against each
other and like talking about price I
mean I really felt for them you know and
then it'd be like okay you guys can go
home okay next you know and I was like
man this is Bruce sweating in my pits
right now for you I like you know we
lied I'm not really great
did you play sports I did not believe
ask about yeah I why didn't let I didn't
islands claimed that was actually in the
director was like he was really funny
that's what I'm most worried about you
know the game it seems like the acting
this stuff that all the other the drama
he was like you gotta be you know I
watch like tape of coaches and stuff and
the thing that was the most important
for me was like to develop a
relationship with these guys develop all
kind of a rapport and I think it's great
the chemistry is great I don't know I
mean you're all great actors if it
wasn't really great in person I know
that it's awkward to ask in front of it
but I want the T what is the best story
the best Bend story will do yes well
don't be afraid okay be afraid yeah okay
well when we were shoot there's a scene
of the movie I don't give away a lot but
the skirmish breaks out and we and we
you know the bench is cleared and I
remember I'm in like the group of all
these dudes and we're fighting and
whatever fake fighting and I just feel
it's dude come up behind me and just
like grab me like this and just rip me
out of the pile and then I look back and
it was Ben Affleck and I was like that's
that's how strong Batman is supposed to
be
I feel bad for the Joker's like henchmen
like that okay
losing Batman would have picked the
smallest guy did anybody else get a bear
hug from Batman no but man we were three
weeks in June I didn't have no lines we
were just doing all of the basketball
stuff so when we had the scene where he
introduces himself as the coach I was so
happy I'm like I finally get to speak
finally and so I remember when I got
ready to save my lines and this guy cuts
my line off and so I let it slide
[Applause]
he did it cuz he did it one more time
and I was like oh no this I'm not gonna
do I'm not taking this ride on Ben
Affleck cool so I just remember I was
talking with Melbourne in the group I
said I'm about to tell Ben Affleck off
and they were like you know are you
crazy don't do it and I ran over it and
I sprinted and I hit it right on the
chest aside hey I was like hey man you
stepping on my lines what's up with that
you know I mean I'm proud of my lot of
it wait in a minute I told him Ben
Affleck you're Ben Affleck you were in
this movie you got all the lines Oh got
that mini life I need all the chances I
could get and I had the script and I was
telling them but oh my gosh this story
has grown
I stepped on a line once his line was
what I was like this guy is not going to
let any he was like was what throwback
Thursday photo with a story behind it I
will go first because mine is probably
the most embarrassing where is that okay
so my mom we were real broke because my
mom is a teacher and they make no money
it's horrible anyway so my mom would do
this thing where we couldn't afford to
go on vacations she just cut our
pictures out around her head and then
place us in landscaped so this was my
favorite trip to the Swiss out
like she would just take my random
photos and here's the best part we
didn't probably pay for that either you
know they give you like the one that
says like photo on it like and you just
kind of what we chopped the bottom off
and then then you don't pay for the
pictures note to self but anyway this
was my throwback my mom was well she was
artistic hyouta 'fl woman you Brandon
we're gonna go brand him first here's
Brandon's throwback is that fake behind
you we're real you talking about the
jheri-curl behind my head I was just
kidding you're my landscape alright will
is next let's see it I was everyone
except Batman that Bessel basically last
year what's going on here though are you
flying off the tree or what hi I don't
know I hope onto a ladder or something
look I don't think that was very high up
now so we're good all right you're that
uqt Lakers oh my god yeah no I like his
man yep
[Applause]
little player what are you wearing are
you in like a show
no so bro that is that prohibition night
[Applause]
growing up as a kid mama I used to dress
like that every day for school I'm not
kidding I used to dress like that in
suits all day every day I was with my
dad I was going to go to church there's
a hat on the chain and I don't even know
what's it like this massive rapper bling
you do look like a mini Bernie Mac I
would love for my kids to her I might be
young guess is three so I could put my
boy in stuff like this and he still has
no like say but it's we're getting close
to he Wally I can't believe you let your
mom do that all the all the layers I was
like four or five years old my mom would
what knew you five do you know what
we're very similar look at your grease
lightening hair what is happening here
that is and you're looking at the
personal yeah yes that's Craigslist and
I'm trying to know I
that was an after-school special the one
thing I did one little thing I did
besides that kids show up for PBS the
cameraman said I want my filming a
little apps especially should come in an
audition I went in an audition it was
about this little boy and his best
friend and they they this is how long
ago it was they took out a personal ad
there was no internet for his mom
because there was a single mom he trying
to set her up and the director came in
was like really cool and want to put
their artistic bent on it so she was
like I think your punk rocker I was like
I don't even know what that means but
apparently that's what it meant
you do look rock Andreas
I think I still win with the fake
background but whatever um who's who's
competitive not me subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going